hey you guys it's fried again time for
another movie retrospective and again
we're doing another horror classic from
the 1980s yeah the evil did yeah this is
a good one it's up there with you know
like read the reanimate or series and
phantasm you know series and Evil Dead
is really one of those few and I think
we mentioned this maybe on one of our
maybe our phantasm show that I think
Evil Dead is the only horror franchise
that either got better it was just as
good like all of the you know attendance
sequels and all of the things that you
know were made outside of you know in
other mediums we're all work just as
good and I think Evil Dead is like a
really prime example of that yeah some
people would even argue that Evil Dead 2
was better than Evil Dead 1 I'm not sure
about that they're kind of different
movies the second ones kind of a remake
of the first but my friend from Mexico
Joy here he's watching reanimate her for
the first time the entire series yeah
and he says it's getting better as it
goes along - yeah it's the first time
he's ever seen it yeah ok he's like our
age so he has like a Joker perspective
out yeah I would say that reanimate ER
series the Evil Dead series and the
phantasm series are pretty unique in
that they got better as they went yeah
and I put those all about neck and neck
and the interesting thing about the Evil
Dead series too is that it's such a
simple premise like we said about
phantasm it's like the reason that
worked is because the mythology was so
strange and it was kind of wide-ranging
that was a lot you can do with it yeah
very unique right but like on the other
hand the Evil Dead franchise is
basically like a demon zombie type thing
and it's pretty simple but they still
did like some interesting things and
when in interesting directions with it
you know obviously army of Darkness
which was a third one I didn't see the
remake I'll admit I'm I don't know if it
was as good as the original but and I
also loved the TV show that's on Starz
ash vs. Evil Dead which is actually one
of the most wonderful TV shows ever and
you get to see Bruce Campbell's face
stuck in a corpses [ __ ]
yeah and that's worth the entire price
of admission that was like the funniest
thing I've ever seen I always I always
saw the Evil Dead as
kind of like a like an action version of
The Exorcist
imagine if the edges interesting way of
putting yeah magic if the Exorcist was
an action that it was funniest funny as
hell I don't I mean so there was kind of
like some slapstick horror in it yeah
mixed with mixed with zombies imagine
you know there isn't a isn't there if
there isn't a living body to inhabit
that the demons will inhabit or they'll
possess a dead body yeah and make kind
of like a you know like a zombie but it
would also inhabit trees and possess
trees you know because we possessed
books the Necronomicon is in it
yeah it's mentioned in it which is a
little nod to Lovecraft so that it's
almost kind of like you could say it
might be a Lovecraft spin-off it is kind
of and they actually the original title
of it was Book of the Dead and it was
supposed to be like a Lovecraftian type
of invocation thing when they were first
thinking about it I think what makes the
Evil Dead work and I why even a lot of
people still love it today and it's like
really one of the best you know
well-regarded movies of the ADA is not
if not just of the 80s but in horror
movies in general um I think it's its
best quality is its exuberance yeah you
can tell the people were they were very
young they loved this [ __ ] and it's just
like the you know even though the
filming of it was famously not very
pleasant for everyone involved because
it was just this horrible ordeal but you
could tell that they really it was like
a labor of love they were having a ton
of fun this was Sam Raimi's first
feature-length movie and he is obviously
a very innovative filmmaker and you can
see that very clearly just even even in
this cheap-jack movie that they made for
like what like three hundred fifty
thousand dollars maybe I think it was
just some like some piddling amount so
but I I'm really a fascinated by like
the history like the production history
of this movie because like I said this
was Sam Raimi's first feed only made
short films prior to this him and Bruce
Campbell actually grew up together they
were kids together and they made like a
little you know super 8 movies and [ __ ]
like that they actually started out
doing comedy but they kind of said well
let's do a horror movie but the first
thing we'll do they had the idea so
of the Evil Dead but they actually made
it a short film first called within the
woods and it had a similar premise and
they said we'll make this short movie
and then we'll show it to investors to
get money to like expand it to full
length and that actually did end up
working out they didn't get as much
money as they wanted but they did were
able to like borrow money from friends
and family and various investors and
stuff and they got like kind of enough
money to cobble something together so
they all go out to Tennessee to the
infamous cabin they were actually
staying in that cabin while they were
filming it I didn't have any plumbing
[ __ ] like that so that they're like so
it was like close quarters they had like
one guy on the crew that was like a
carpenter and he was like doing all the
art direction that was pretty much what
you see in the cabin in the movie is
just pretty much the way it was they
didn't really have any money to like set
dress it or anything like that so that's
pretty much kind of what it looked like
and when the movie was finished and it
came out like Sam Raimi was taking it
around and showing it to like everybody
he knew and he happened to come across
this guy named Irvin Shapiro and Irvin
Shapiro was the guy who had distributed
Night of the Living Dead you know the
very famous George Romero movie and he
said oh I think you've kind of got
something here
so he said that he would distribute it
he also urban Shapiro also happened to
be one of the founders of the very
famous Cannes Film Festival in France so
he said well I'll give you a showing at
the Cannes Film Festival so at that
showing was none other than Stephen King
and Stephen King saw the Evil Dead and
loved that [ __ ] yeah so so him like
raving about it and bring up and just
talking about this this is like this
amazing movie and it's like this this
new talent is like kind of coming out of
nowhere and so him pushing it like
really kind of got you know got a
distribution deal and it actually ended
up when it first came out what they did
they kind of like released it they did
they took like Bruce Campbell's the the
theater in Detroit that he had grown up
going to and they did like a whole
William Castle like premiere there they
had like ambulances parked outside like
in case anybody had a heart attack or
anything there like all the gimmick you
got
[ __ ] I didn't know he was from Troy
therefore they're all from Michigan yeah
okay it's all starting to make sense now
because never when I told you the first
time I saw this is in Trenton Michigan
yeah and it was in a drive-in theater
yeah and I could have swore that they
were playing part 1 and part 2
back-to-back and everybody was there
well that's you know that would have
been their territory yeah submit that's
it so and I think it was after two Evil
Dead 2 had come out yeah it was shared
like a double feature
yeah when what year did evil did to come
out 87 I think okay yeah the dates are
all making sense that's that's about the
time and then army of Darkness came out
of night three I think yeah that was a
wild night when we saw that man
everybody everybody I knew was there in
that theater in that driving yeah and
people these young people they don't
never know the driving was all I would
have honestly loved to seen in there man
the drive-in was a cross between
Woodstock a cheap motel and all your
friends were there you'd look in a very
very back row with all the cars in the
very very back you see what your friends
car back there and he'd be back in there
and the car be bouncing you knew what
was going on because sometimes even get
serious you had to throw it in reverse
and go to the back all right excuse yeah
and this was in the 80s now you know it
was a different time sometime there were
four people in those cars well you know
yeah double date sometimes man hey
keeping high fives across the seat you
know it is a fancy what's up man you
know it was another time I actually did
see I was too young to see it when I
first came on the theater but I actually
thought when they rereleased it whenever
they did the theater rereleased I
actually did see it then and I hadn't
seen it for many years so that was like
a lot of fun but the cool thing like I
said the cool thing about this movie yes
it's very cheaply made yeah like some of
the acting stuff I mean other than Bruce
Campbell who obviously is amazing you
know some of the acting is kind of you
know whatever but the thing about it
that I love like I said is just how it's
like just this joyful crazy let's just
make the most ridiculous over-the-top
just all this over-the-top gore or just
just gets sillier and sillier
and it's like like I said the camerawork
is really innovative and it's funny
because they did that for like nothing
like Sam Raimi he didn't have enough
money to buy to rent a camera dolly or
anything like that so he would like he
like would mount the camera like on a
plank of wood and like two guys would
like run around and sing it
it's like he mounted it on a bike at one
yeah and the first one you know people
did one it looks kind of rough to make
up it doesn't mean it's obviously a
bunch of you know blue makeup on people
with yeah you know but it didn't matter
in those days when we saw these yeah it
was over the top they were kind of zany
but they still scared us and that's
something that I think a lot of maybe
maybe people don't understand the day
you know people are very hardened to
imagery young kids can see some wild
[ __ ] and it doesn't doesn't really
bother them they know it's fake Yammy
tree doesn't affect him that would still
scare the [ __ ] out of us though we'd
laugh and Dan it would scare us at the
same time that was one of the best
things about this movie too is that it
was yes it's very funny it's very it was
creepy yeah yeah it was like really kind
of creepy in those days yeah like it and
I think a lot of it was due to again
like a lot of Sam Raimi's camerawork
like he did like these strange close-ups
like these strange Dutch angles like the
whole I love that one this movie doesn't
[ __ ] around it's like there's maybe a
couple minutes of like all the people
going to the cabin hey we're going to
the cabin blah blah blah and then they
find it then like literally two minutes
later you know the girl Cheryl is like
drawing the clock and the clock stops
and then there's like this creepy and
[ __ ] and then immediately like demon
this sound and everything raised trees
there was everything and it was also the
times was weird you know like in those
days you weren't really supposed to be
watching these these were almost kind of
like almost kind of like a little taboo
underground movies there was almost kind
of like watching some kind of snuff
flick or something they weren't
mainstream they were kind of underground
yeah so you always had a feeling feeling
when you're watching these is that you
were watching something you really
weren't supposed to be seeing yeah you
weren't supposed to be watching these
there was they were subversive yeah
there was some kind of like grimy yeah
thing about them yeah like
normal society the people that were
older than us did not approve of these
we have grown up with them as teenagers
were oh man it was [ __ ] badass but
adults were saying no we wouldn't like
these they're like oh that's - that
shit's terrible all night common oh
that's terrible yeah yeah like the guy
never stick-in-the-mud so you know it
was kind of like punk rock and yeah yeah
that's a good analogy actually that's
exactly I was like and I mean it's funny
now because it seemed like it seems like
horror and punk and stuff like that is
so mainstreamed but when we were there
yeah yeah it was like that was like a
big thing and like I said you know home
video had just come into the fore and
like so they had like all these cheap
like horror movies and you could just go
rent them and you know there was really
something about the atmosphere of
watching these videos like you said that
looked like just somebody made it in
their backyard very something like
culturally subversive yeah the
mainstream culture was not really
smiling on these movies and people going
to see an especially young people this
was something that they would have liked
to have stopped actually I
yeah there was just that it was going on
anyway and like I said you know where I
was at those days you know we had
drive-in still you know which they were
dinosaurs when I was a kid yeah and the
[ __ ] that was going on in drive-ins was
pretty off-the-wall yeah and it was all
high school kids we're women
we were feral back then you would just
disappear for hours at a time yet no
idea water drinking what but yeah I mean
the interesting thing about the Evil
Dead though and this actually didn't
happen with a lot of horror movies I
mean I feel like in the 70s horror got a
little more legitimate because there was
some kind of high profile like
big-budget horror films you know like
The Omen and you know the shining a
little bit later that were made by you
know established filmmakers and they had
big budgets and they were actually like
critically acclaimed and stuff but a lot
of these kind of really cheap indie
horror movies I feel like a like a lot
of critics were just like man whatever
they were just garbage but the
interesting thing about the first Evil
Dead is that even when it came out in
1981 it was pretty much universally
loved I mean overall the critic the
critics were like this is [ __ ] great
it's just like it's so fun it's like you
know all like I said all the innovative
camerawork and just all the exuberance
of it so it's interesting because it was
recognized I mean [ __ ] I think even the
Los Angeles Times said back in 1981 they
called it an instant classic so I think
people did recognize at the time which
didn't always happen with these types of
movies and it seems like it's reputation
just kind of grew and grew over yeah
only the cool people liked it though you
know
and nothing is I'm literally literally
it was punk rock on on screen yeah it
had a big influence in the goth and
industrial scene I mean there's a really
famous goth industrial band called
Skinny Puppy and it Rob's some so many
audio samples of dialogues from all the
Evil Dead movies and you'll you'll hear
dialog from the movies and sound effects
from the movies in in Skinny Puppy songs
yeah and very effective because the
movies weren't that old when those
albums were coming out and I'd hear them
and you'd hear those demons sound you go
oh I know what that is oh [ __ ] creeped
you out some of the Skinny Puppy albums
you know you didn't really want to
listen to those with them with the
lights off when you were a kid you know
five can't sing a kid you know late
teens early 20s
some of the stuff sounded like it was
gonna summon demons those albums are
kind of like haunted house music being
played backwards with a bunch of demonic
voices happening with drum machines
going backwards and stuff and it's weird
I mean you never know what you're gonna
invoke when you might invoke it in that
type of wide evoke that damn tree demon
that come out rape you remember that one
that is simultaneously one of the it's
it's like you're watching the scene and
I can't and I can imagine like the first
time everybody saw this cuz I don't
think I ever saw that in another movie
ever before or since and it's kind of
just like you're watching you're just
like no that's that's no it's gonna have
that's how it's gonna happen in the your
tentacle porn oh my god it is that
they're going
there and they did go there I mean
pretty much put that would honor yeah
tree rape you don't get that never yeah
I'm just saying the only thing I can
another thing that I remembered about
these movies is that I have a hard time
remembering the difference between Evil
Dead One and Evil Dead two very similar
yeah I remember that too looked a lot
better but there were times where I'm
thinking well when's this gonna happen I
was like oh yeah that was part of one oh
that was part two then that happens they
seem because they're happening in the
same location and a lot of times I got
them confused
yeah like I said they're very similar
it's almost seems like the the second
ones kind of a remake of the first with
a higher budget yeah it's like the first
one remade with a better budget yeah I
mean the the thing is it's like when
Evil Dead was released like I said it
kind of got like a soft release he kind
of toward it and then they released it
in theaters and on VHS kind of at the
same time in the theaters it ended up
making well over to me two million
dollars which not too bad because it
only cost it cost less than half a
million to make so it made its budget
back and then some interestingly it did
much much better in Europe they [ __ ]
love that [ __ ] over there and in fact in
the UK that was the year it came out on
VHS it was easily the highest you know
it sold the most copies of any other VHS
I never saw it on VHS back in the day
never oh I first saw him both the same
day in that damn Drive driving
yeah and in Evil Dead one already had a
killer reputation so I knew I was in
store for some [ __ ] yeah yeah and I mean
when I saw it I remember it blowing me
away but there was other stuff going on
too and like I'm saying a drive-in was a
damn party yeah so you know kinda [ __ ]
was happening the only horror movie I
remember seeing in the theater I think I
thought Texas Chainsaw Massacre - the
one with Dennis Hopper I'm pretty sure I
said that in the drive-in but at that
stage I mean I grew up in Daytona Beach
Florida and we had one drive-in theater
left and it was like pretty much on its
last legs by that point so it was just
kind of like they were begging people to
come in there but I think that was like
no I know I had to take that back I saw
scanners driving
also I remember that I don't think I saw
this in the drive-in I did see it on VHS
a few times and I might have seen it on
cable and then like I said when they did
the re-release of the of it in the
theaters I went and saw it again then
but it's just like I said its reputation
is just grown over the years they made
so many holy [ __ ] man it's like not only
have they made the three movies they
made the TV show they did a remake in
2013
there's a [ __ ] Evil Dead the musical
there's there's a series of comics where
ash fights Freddy and Jason there's one
where ash fights zombie versions of a
bunch of Marvel characters there's like
so it's just like this whole ridiculous
and this obviously was where Bruce
Campbell's you know cult icon status
came from this pretty good movie and
it's funny because we were watching the
first Evil Dead which is actually on
shudder at the moment I'd forgotten how
[ __ ] young he was because there I
mean we've been watching ash vs. Evil
Dead you know what he's obviously much
older now even though like I said if you
haven't seen that show you should watch
it because it's [ __ ] awesome it's
[ __ ] awesome but um but he was like I
mean he was just a kid in this movie was
like 19 or 20 or some [ __ ] like that
it's like amazing
but this just kind of just goes to show
like I said it's kind of like George
Romero's zombie movies it's kind of like
if you have a bunch of friends and you
really really really want to make a
movie and can beg people to make money
and you really want to do it and these
people did it and now Sam Raimi is
making [ __ ] spider-man movies yeah
and [ __ ] like that it's like look how
that happens I know it's probably rare
like a lot there's nowadays since the
[ __ ] I'm not sure if anything like
this could happen to nowadays I don't
think it happens this way anymore
yeah it doesn't because I mean too much
competition yeah the whole you know the
whole kind of format of everything has
changed because now the means of
production are so cheap right very much
anybody I mean you can make a movie with
your [ __ ] phone if you really wanted
to so it's it's not like it was back in
the day where you just kind of had to
like innovate because you couldn't
really afford the equipment and all this
other kind of stuff and then you had to
like you know beg people to like make a
movie it took a half a million dollars
to make a movie that nowadays like you
said you can make on your make on your
phone and you had your friends helping
you you could probably make it for a cup
thousand dollars now yeah you could yeah
if people were chipping in and working
for free even a couple thousand bucks
yeah and I mean that's probably
essentially the the first iteration of
you know that you can do Evo dead one
for that yeah I mean the first iteration
of evil that they made which is within
the woods which is a short film they
made that for about sixteen hundred
dollars I'm really was that little yeah
but I don't it was short I don't know
how long it was but so you know like I
said the the budget for the first Evil
Dead I've seen it everywhere from a
hundred thousand to three hundred fifty
thousand it did make like eight times
its money back you know in its initial
theater run and like I said it was very
good one investment yes it was a very
very very well reviewed movie and like I
said its reputation has just grown over
the years and it I mean if you're into
horror and you haven't seen it then you
can't be that into horror because
everybody's seen this [ __ ] move yeah
that's kind of like saying you know
being a Christian you haven't read
Genesis it's one of the flood evil yeah
but what's evil dead yeah that's what I
mean it's like anybody that's into
horror if you must have seen this movie
so one of the formative movies of the
horror genre particularly eighties but
each of the of the genre as so much of
the genre today is actually influenced
from those early movies phantasm one
Evil Dead one reanimate er yeah you know
a lot of the modern kind of zany horror
is from that I see that over and over
again yeah it's a yeah you kind of see
it echoes of it in kind of more recent
movies like doctor and Dale vs. evil
stuff like that which is that kind of
over-the-top hilarious like super super
gory but also super super funny and I
kind of feel like this is sort of now I
did want to mention to wait to a
separate show on this but have you ever
seen Sam Raimi's more recent film drag
me to hell no you would probably like
that very much
it's a you know it's yeah it's it's
actually really good I enjoyed it I
remember seeing it at the theater but
it's it's not as quite as zany but it
still has that same kind of feeling to
it what's funny is that we're calling is
a knee now but I remember seeing it when
it came out as a kid it still scared us
but like I said it's a knee in creepy
yeah like it goes like over the
top and you weren't sure really how you
were supposed to react to it yeah and
then something else would happen you
like oh whoa whoa that's it and then the
hand he cuts his own hand off it whoa
that's weird you know but yeah seriously
why are we sure how how we were supposed
to react to it because that concept was
so new yeah yeah I think like I said
that was one of the best things about it
cuz there's a lot of screaming out a lot
of blood so of course it scared you
cuz there really not been anything like
that so it really kind of blew the doors
off yeah that type of thing and like I
said it wasn't a genre yet yeah the
thing but like I said the thing that I
found the most fascinating is that is
how popular it was even when it first
came out cuz they said it sometimes it
takes time for movies to kind of be like
oh yeah we did we revisited it and that
was a good movie and even though nobody
liked it at the time but this was like
totally different this one was like
pretty much universally I don't think
there was any well you know I don't like
phantasm one was a little bit before
this I believe and I believe the
phantasm one as soon as it was made
everybody in my school I remember
talking about like a late elementary
school you know yeah and we were all
scared of that move you know only a
couple kids had seen it and we were
asking what did it happen ago the ball
hit you in the head and then a bunch of
water with like a juicer you know I mean
and we didn't know whether to believe
their lies this saw it you're making
that up yeah because we didn't have main
that cable that Janna and then that
movie vanished they never played that
one on cable yeah so me and my buddies
we always kind of thought that that was
kind of like a taboo movie something you
weren't supposed to see yeah I didn't
see it until recently again that's funny
it's like and I think it's just
something is kind of lacking in a lot of
new ones because like I said people are
so jaded now and we've seen anything I
mean back at the back in the day it was
like you weren't you weren't really sure
what you're gonna see cuz it's just kind
of like people were all over the place
and they weren't sure what the
technology was well yeah they could
actually show you it was like all these
little scrappy independent the directors
and they were making all this stuff and
you weren't really sure what they could
do and
a lot of stuff hadn't been done yet I do
kind of feel like now most stuff has
been done you don't really see I mean
I'm not saying there's there's good
movies now too but it's harder to hard
it's harder to do something original
because you know a lot of stuff so most
of the time it's just kind of you're
just paying homage to something that's
already been done I'm skeptical of
movies now in a way they really have to
do something to make something special
now because it's almost seems like it's
a dying art form like a dying medium I
think it might go the way of like epic
poetry or something you know I think
video games really you know maybe
virtual reality type stuff is probably
the future and then even now to probably
get old
well everything everything is this old
the great circle of life eventually
they'll just be plugging in directly to
your brain and they'll be giving you
hallucinations you know directly into
your brain and that's that will be the
movie and then I'll just be like wall-e
where overall there's these big fat
slugs like laying around yeah you just
float around on your lounge chair and
robot to bring you sodas and [ __ ] not
good not good
you haven't seen Frank Frank Hubert were
were warned about in dune yeah it's why
they occur but yeah Frank that's why
they banned computers he had to have man
tats and mental powers and yeah cuz
there are free computers make everybody
well they did they had overthrow them
yeah yeah cool then they wrote it into
their holy books and [ __ ] I knew dunas
common people yeah same dude who did the
new Blade Runner I hope it's good and I
love the new Blade Runner
yeah we did a review on that too I'm a
big dune fan yeah I know anyway but yeah
so like I said if you haven't seen Evil
Dead again what's the matter with you
you really need to get on that right now
I feel like this is kind of cool because
I'm glad we had shudder because they
have a lot of really classic horror
movies on there that we hadn't done so
we're gonna plug in shudder again for
free well hey shudder you owe us money
they have a lot of good [ __ ] on there
yeah actually we watched a movie on
there last night that you really liked
and you know how picky he is yeah I'm
very picky
I'm just called change haned he was
pretty with the Vincent Donofrio
dude it played a kingpin kingpin on that
and he's like a serial killer and that
was a very very compelling movie he
actually paid it to get off his tablet
yeah hours and paid attention that one
disturbed me that's huge you that one
disturbed it it was very disturbing
I thought yeah I liked the interaction
between it was very good the acting was
very good so you know check it out but
yeah so original Evil Dead is on shudder
to a bunch of other ones its Halloween's
coming up so you might want to go check
that out but yeah so I guess that will
do it for our review of the classic 1981
people dead yeah so remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media go to our patreon page
or our blog you know how it goes if you
watch the show I just say the regular
[ __ ] all the time
also remember that our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday movie reviews
every Friday and also we started the new
thing where we're reviewing movies in
the theater and that goes out every
Sunday so there'll be a new one up on
Sunday so check that out too and until
next time bye